Teesha elude keeper of balance bless the
maker and his water bless the coming and
going of him may his passage cleanse the
world
you
it is said that worms up to 450 meters
roam in the deep deserts of Arrakis the
beasts are nearly indestructible they
possess rows of razor-sharp teeth and
fiercely defend their territory there
are very few ways to kill an Arrakis
sandworm Atomics are the only explosives
capable since each segment of the worms
body has a life of its own smaller
explosions have little effect Atomics
however are banned throughout the
Imperium men have agreed to preserve
them for any future alien threat another
way is through an electric shock of an
extremely high voltage applied to each
segment of the worms body separately and
lastly water is poisonous to the great
worms but it never rains on Arrakis to
understand the sand worms of dune you
must first understand why there is
almost no water on Arrakis tiny
creatures known as sandy plankton feed
upon the microscopic traces of melange
found throughout the deserts of Arrakis
these plankton are food for the sand
worms but also grow to be what the
Fremen call little makers these little
makers or sand trout block off water
into pockets below the planet's surface
but these beings were not always on
Arrakis the sand route was introduced
here from some other place this was a
wet planet then they Pole if rated
beyond the capability of existing
ecosystems to deal with them sand route
insisted the available free water made
this a desert planet and they did it to
survive
in a planet sufficiently dry they could
move to their sandworm phase when the
excretions of the sand trout come into
contact with water they form what is
called a pre spiced mass gases are
produced within the pocket due to
fungicide growth eventually the pressure
builds and you get what is referred to
as a spice below the mass of Sam trout
rushes to the surface killing most of
the little makers the spice mass once
exposed to the air and Sun becomes the
addictive spice melange the few
surviving sand trout would coalesce and
enter a semi dormant cyst hibernation
and emerge six years later as a small
worm no larger than three metres in
length
only a small number avoid their larger
cousins long enough to become mature
worms however in the desert worms are
attracted to and maddened by the
presence of hopes Minh force fields
which are used as defensive shields in
the doom universe such devices are of
little use in the desert
since the worms attack rhythmic motions
the Fremen people of the desert have
learned to avoid worm attacks by
mimicking the motions of desert animals
moving with the natural sounds of the
desert the worms of Arrakis are the only
source of the spice melange and the
water of life by drowning a stunted worm
a primitive form of the sand worms that
only reach about nine meters in length
the water of life is produced the truth
Sayre drug the deadly narcotic than the
Binnie jezzer it used to unblock their
genetic memory though these creatures
are formidable the Fremen people
utilized them in a way that no others
can learn the worm by the vibration of a
thumper a device created by the Freeman
the lead Runner can run alongside the
beasts and snare one of its ring
segments with a special hook
crying the segments open exposing the
soft inner tissue to the abrasive
and flowing due to the worms movement as
a result the worm will rotate its body
so that the exposed flesh faces upward
carrying the rider with it a worm can be
ridden for hundreds of miles before it
becomes exhausted
it is not known where the sand trout
originally came from only that they
changed the ecology of the planet dude
now without them all tre throughout the
known in varium would cease space travel
would in and millions would die from
spice withdrawal
[Music]
you
you